5 13 into friday morning what's cool at
school well last week we told you about
a team of junior high school kids
winning a robotics competition now how
about a team of young women who want a
different robotics event
my name is zelia i'm diana i'm emma i'm
mia i'm kennedy and i'm nadia this group
of seventh and eighth graders from the
pinecrest academy's sloan canyon campus
call themselves the amazons their robot
the quacken won the robot skills
champion award at the state level zeldia
says the goal of the challenge was to
collect the balls from the field and
shoot them into the goal and while that
worked great it was the team's
successful participation in the optional
biomimicry competition that guaranteed
them a spot in the world championships
in dallas in may hey amazon emma what's
biomimicry
according to the biomimicry institute
biomimicry is a practice that learns
from and mimics the strategies found in
nature to solve human design challenges
they brainstormed researched and
designed a robot to expand what's
currently being done in search and
rescue efforts after building collapses
it's small and flexible for easy
navigation it's also equipped with
several touch distance and ultrasonic
sensors in order to collect and send
back information and video about the
class this will help search and rescue
locate missing people and decide where
they should or shouldn't send an actual
workers
wow i mean when i was in seventh grade i
was concerned about what was for lunch
these kids are out to change the world
so the amazons they are just one of six
teams coached by anna egbert and they
are all looking for a little help from
the community as they work towards an
estimated fifty thousand dollars needed
to send forty students and six
chaperones on that trip to dallas in may
now the amazons have already earned
fifteen hundred dollars by holding a
sold out robotics camp for elementary
students this afternoon we've got a link
to their donation page on our website
eightnewsnow.com you know some cool at
school let us know cool at school under
the community tab at datenewsnow.com or
email cool at school at eightnewsnow.com
i mean that's just amazing that these
kids did this research found out about
this biomimicry they said you know what
if we can build a robot that imitates
snakes
we can get them into these building
collapses
and have s it was just crazy fine people
yeah i mean it makes perfect sense but
wow